[Music]
ran through this
world in my
glove Together We
Roll never
alone still to his
train Ming light
going to make you laugh time after
[Applause]
time
[Music]
roll remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at
louderwithcrowder.com mug club
today
[Music]
[Applause]
Str that's what I
[Music]
know
all right mug club and all you other
people I know what you're thinking right
now don't don't leave don't
just it's okay everything's going to be
fine we're going to have a fantastic
time here I have other people in the
studio that are going to make sure of
that but look we look what we did to the
set here we've got all the Christmas
stuff up we've got the I don't know why
we have the one thing like right here
it's always like that every single year
is that supposed to be like brown yeah
Charlie Brown okay that makes sense I
guess that makes some I guess by the way
before you say it another Rumble things
out of focus it's called depth the field
I mean come on little
inside had to explain that to so now
you're going to have to explain people
are going to be asking you like hey tol
man I'll do it on Twitter okay there you
go fantastic all right well look we have
a fantastic show this is our last show
before Thanksgiving and so um we talked
a little bit about some of the
Thanksgiving food and traditions that we
all had uh yesterday but we're going to
do uh chat Tuesday today for mug club
and we also have a story um that there's
no way that we could cover on this but
let me go through the rest of the
rundown for today's show so we have a
this weekend Biden for you because he
tends to say really stupid things almost
every single week really we could do
this segment every week but we choose
not to do that to you also Napoleon
movie uh is premiering I guess tomorrow
and so we're going to talk about uh
their Revolution versus our Revolution
and their Revolution sucks compared to
ours and just letting you know why also
Elon Musk is being accused of being an
anti-semite and uh he went a bit nuclear
his words thermonuclear yeah which I
didn't think was necessary to say it
like that but he did so fine you're Elon
Musk I guess you can do it uh but he
dropped a lawsuit uh last night I
believe uh or yesterday afternoon and a
number of people joined him and I think
the tide is turning and do me a favor
that's my question of the day for you
right now do you think the tide is
turning with all of the I guess Pro uh
Free Speech platforms and groups and
really with some of the the Attorneys
General and that's how you say the
plural of Attorneys General
they're chiming in as well so far I
think we have Texas maybe some other
ones hinting that they're going to join
this do you think the tide is turning
finally on corrupt media not just not
doing a good job of reporting but
actively trying to take out free speech
Advocates comment and let me know what
you think but when you hear one of the
best which one yeah let's go that let's
go that way first yeah so when you one
of the best songs ever if you're a Game
Fan there we go you know the Ginger Snap
Mr Lane the brain is sitting in my chair
how are you sir good loving the new
camera angles over here loving The Vibes
the studio it's a good mood it's not you
don't have the fish Islands anymore over
there so that's I already have a very
bulbous forehead so it really wasn't
doing any
favors is that why you would always
slouch over there you're like I just
want to be as far away from the camera
as possible okay that makes sense we're
good all right fantastic well and if you
hear this music you know Mr Josh
firestein hey hey what's up how are you
good good doing well you ready for some
Mas potatoes oh yeah I've been prepping
all week I haven't eaten a potato in 6
days really yeah that's why you just
want it to be amazing what's a normal
potato interval for you oh yeah like uh
3 hours probably nice you said mashed
potatoes were your favorite right I love
M it's my favorite Thanksgiving food
it's the best it's perfect yes you can
have it all the time though especially
if you have somebody if you go to
somebody else's place and they're
cooking the meat
yeah just bring the mashed potato yeah
bring your own
ters b t got it B and G nice look you're
doing you're you know you like mashed
potatoes so look if you're in the Tacoma
Washington area and you want to come out
to the comedy club on Wednesday November
22nd Josh has a free show do me a favor
bring him some mashed potatoes yeah yes
bring some mashed potatoes I don't know
if you should do that though that maybe
have somebody else try them first
there's like four or five other
comedians on the show and they would
love that too I'm sure they would oh
yeah what if somebody poisons it
yeah Zack Summerfield's on the show and
I could deal with that maybe don't bring
them they're not very portable like
they're
portable just put them in one of the I'm
not bringing your Tupperware back to you
though all right no that's this is we're
throwing Tupperware away at this point
right but you can put them in one of
those like things that like you know
holds the heat in the restaurants give
you you know the to-go containers that
have like the foil look to them I don't
know maybe that's the best way to do
people just have those stash way in
their kitchen I think they do I think I
mean it just you just whatever you
figure it out hey Ginger Snap looks good
you look good with the light behind you
and whatever that thing is next to you I
don't know what that is that the field
yeah it's out of focus behind him so you
have to do that by the way I'm not sure
if you're aware looking M vul over there
I love one of the one of the first
things that I did was mcol Hulan mcy
Vulcan Vulcan I don't know if I like
either of those things I don't know it
matters one of the first things that I
did though was I gave Tool Man a hard
time I'm like hey Tim the rumble sign's
out of focus and he goes yes Gerald I
know like cuz if if we're to be in Focus
you would but I'm but I'm the CEO can we
make it in Focus he's like that's not
how it works doesn't matter that you're
a CEO and I was like oh fine I was like
hey maybe we can one day have everything
in Focus money I don't know we'll see
and then he's like well actually this
looks better and I said oh fine you you
do your job and I'll do poorly mine the
CEO
stuff so that's why I had to lead the
show and by the way I do have a cough
drop in my mouth so if you hear that
every once in a while I apologize I'm
still recovering my my dip I thought you
had a Copenhagen in there no man I ain't
dipping long cut I Ain doing that bunch
of my friends did in high school and I
just saw one of my buddies this was the
last time he dipped just sprinting in
we're sitting in the restaurant and he's
running from the back parking lot around
he had swallowed his dip on accident no
and he was sprinting towards the toilet
to vomit so that he could eat gross
that's a great way I wouldn't even eat
at that point oh god oh he was he was he
was yuza is losing it yuza I don't want
to talk don't you do it I'm getting hot
mouth all right so if you dip don't
swallow it doesn't turn out well one
time at a party I drank I thought I was
drinking whiskey was it it was a dip SP
oh it was a dip spinner was the worst I
can't drink whiskey now no can't do that
I can't drink dip spin anymore man baby
out with the bath butter
yeah
gross all right well since it is
Thanksgiving on Thursday and we're very
thankful uh uh here at LAD Crowder we're
thankful for you we're thankful for our
mug Club audience and the ability to
have crazy
people have a voice we don't want to
cancel them but we do want to point them
out and make fun of them and here's a
woman on Tik Tok claiming that
Thanksgiving is racist if you are
thinking about not celebrating
Thanksgiving for the very first time
this year hi welcome I've never
celebrated
Thanksgiving I don't think that younger
people under 2 that in our schools every
single November we dressed up as
pilgrims and Indians and sat around and
had a Thanksgiving no you
didn't bombastic side eye why bombastic
anyway so that is obviously not
happening anymore it's a lie won instead
we talk about with our children we talk
about um indigenous people and I'm so
glad my son's my oldest son's school all
they do all month of of November is talk
about indigenous peoples and their
stories I like oh this is what I'm
thankful for this is what I'm grateful
for like it's a little too it's a little
too close to the fax holiday
Thanksgiving for me oh that's um you
know maybe I am Pro censorship I don't
know I'm changing my mind every single
day bro that's sad you sit around and
talk about indigenous people and their
stories yeah that's great I noticed you
didn't say we sit around and talk about
indigenous peoples and their
contributions to society their
inventions their leaders that changed
the world now you talk about their
stories about and look I fine I have
respect for people who were on this land
and I I don't hate any people group that
were here I just think that we won and
uh we we took the L now if you want to
get mad at us for not honoring an
agreement or something like that fine we
can talk about that but it was such a
long time ago who has the time to be
fair indigenous studies is fun it's fun
to learn about how the cles raped and
pillaged and wiped out the Apache
Apaches probably my favorite part of
indigenous I think so too how they were
just kind of fighting each other the
entire time and doing it in completely
barbaric ways didn't even domesticate
the horse gosh you know Wheels were
around and were a thing it's it's a
failed civil iiz Tock them rather
than there was there was like 7200 it is
a failed group of civilizations they all
failed equally s fantastic seals were
pretty nice seals were cool there's yeah
we don't know Pocahontas I guess it was
fine everything was fine until you guys
decided to be jerks I'm just saying she
wasn't hot though that's a no she was
ugly that's why everybody said she was
hot
totally she looked like a bubblebee yeah
exactly There's real pictures of her she
was busted she's a babe she was busted
yeah she was busted I don't even know
what to think about the words that are
coming out of that man's mouth over
there see if we can find a picture yeah
so by the way if what did John Smith
look like was John Smith uh a killer a
handsome dude Chad he was he probably
yeah okay jeez this he just knows too
many of those like gen z words mhm I
don't even want to get into that game
but look know too we're going to talk
about a number of things including some
things about Pocahontas that are not
very flattering let me tell you that uh
and uh we uh we might have to hit this
this little thing right right yeah so if
you see this just head on over to rumble
I don't know why you're on YouTube
anyway it it shouldn't be a thing at
this point we've given you I don't know
two years to kind of figure this out but
we love Rumble and we're going to get
into some stuff about Rumble and x and
true social and all kinds of great stuff
but before we do that it's always fun to
get to make fun of Joe B we had to
actually cut a few things out of this
because there were too many things that
we could say but he had a really busy
week in San Francisco cow Towing to uh
uh she and running out of meetings so
that he could go to the restroom that's
always fun but uh he pardoned some
turkeys and you know made some mistakes
there as well so that brings us to this
weekend Biden if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're from me or
Trump and you ain't black miles you
could say even this harder than getting
a a ticket to the Renaissance tour or or
or R Britney tour she's down in it's
kind of warm in Brazil right
now look dinner last night my lady I
told you you sat next to my wife you
were so captivating I was worried she
likes you more than she likes me now I
don't know what a beautiful name that's
my mommy's name well ni s how old are
you
17 she's six six if you have a problem
figuring out whether you're for me or
Trump and you ain't black Biden also
said well that's too many for
me
also what are you doing later yeah you
come to you going to come to my hotel
room got sprinkles I thought 17 sounded
pretty good yeah that's leg in like 13
stage at least right he's just so weird
we were talking about it it looked like
a sweet Grandpa moment for a second but
with Joe Biden nothing's a sweet
anything moment right and he's like a
she's got ear things on and that's
fantastic he like how old are you 17
yeah cuz I want to talk about dating
with a six-year-old I don't understand I
don't have a chip in my brain for where
he goes with his creepy conversations
other than his brain is no no longer
able to with like these Lucid thoughts
to go ooh can't say that out loud and
now it just all comes out because he's
so old and scen now and you're like wow
that's the real Joe Biden coming out
every single day I think that's what's
really going on by the way because you
know he's really old he had a a birthday
uh cake yesterday that had the Flames of
Hell apparently on look at
that that's got to be a fire hazard
right but what he really wanted was a
cake that reminded him of his youth oh I
see that oh wow hadn't seen that
one woo okay so burning AC cross on a
cake that's that's a whole new level of
KKK stuff okay got it pretty popular on
in though you can tell yeah exactly well
yeah it's 31% if you vote for Biden
against Trump oh wow wow geez that's uh
yeah not not looking so good well no was
saying the difference there is 31% of
people that would vote for Biden are
voting for him and 57 are voting just to
vote against Trump where the people that
vote for Trump are actually big Trump
supporters yeah yeah exactly and that's
so it's just an they're the he's the I
guess I have to vote for this guy
because he's not Trump candidate yeah I
think this year I think next year we're
going to have a lot of people the
opposite I really do by this time next
year I think holiday season's going to
end we're going to get uh into the
spring inflation's going to go back up
again or it's not going to no this is
good this is still good he hasn't much
lower percentage of people that actually
like I'm saying I think it'll be
opposite I think it' be a lot of people
voting for Trump because they don't want
to vote for Biden well okay I see what
youan yeah I think so I mean people are
already at a point right now where they
can't they can't imagine it getting much
worse but Joe Biden how many birthdays
do you think this guy has left by the
way do me a favor comment on that
because for him I feel like that's worse
I feel like at a certain point and I
feel this way personally I think you
should just be done you know I would
like to not just kind of languish I've
had you know grandparents that kind of
stayed around and were not the same
person I'm kind of kind of being
somewhat tongue and- cheek but they kind
of stayed around they weren't the same
person that they were over the last
couple of years that's kind of existing
not living right now he just seems like
he's existing and making a fool of
himself and his family but I guess you
know they get to you know be in power
just a little bit longer but look his
family's doing fine they are doing
making fools of themselves making fo of
us they make that too
yeah no they don't they're making fools
of the American people right now kept
comfortable on a bed somewhere and he
should be enoy pres whatever you know
neurons connecting and firing that
however those things work in your brain
he should be enjoying whatever he has
left of that not sitting in the white
house having his diaper changed and
going to bed at 4:00 no he should be
eating ice cream cones and sitting at
Chuck-E-Cheese potatoes absolutely wait
Chucky Cheese yeah because how did I end
up agreeing with that statement that
just came out of your mouth uh it's just
the way I say it oh my gosh just snuck
that right in there look hey thank you
so much to all the mug Club supporters
out there we had so many of you uh join
mug Club when we did release the
Nashville Manifesto and we really
appreciate it but make sure you join Muk
Club it's the only way that any of this
exists $89 a year you get the Alex Jones
Show you get the Hodge twins uncensored
Nick depalo show off limits with Brian
Ken where everything is off limits and
Mr guns and gear plus the Friday show
plus the undercover unit you get all of
those things so make sure you guys go
out and join um and we really really do
appreciate it it is the season for being
thankful and we're thankful for you so
it's also the season to give so you know
maybe do that uh so we do have something
coming up in here by the way release the
manifesto. comom I'll talk about that a
little bit more and give you an update
we're still working on stories related
to this right now um I stuff coming down
the line yeah look every time I hear
somebody go well I can't say make sure
you tune in bro and like get get onto
the show and then you're like well you
don't really have anything that's what
you couldn't say who are you talking
about I'm not talking about any person
in particular what I'm saying is that
it's done a lot most notably recently
but it's done a lot and I don't want you
to think that's what we're doing we're
not we actually have something that if
it's true um and if we can kind of
connect all the dots for you guys with
our undercover team will absolutely
shock you and probably make you uh more
pissed off about this than you already
are which is hard to do I understand
that but I really do think so we'll see
if this actually comes together but we
have people that are you know honest to
God journalists not like medium matters
where they actually go out and try to
confirm things and not contrive things
so we we'll keep you updated on that but
we do have a time of year and I didn't
know this Lane like I didn't think about
this for some reason it didn't connect
in my brain that I like this time of
year for more than just like the
holidays I love Christmas I love
Thanksgiving I love Colder Weather the
snow family like you know the birth of
Christ and
celebrating yeah drel fine um I don't
have any problem with that at all I love
all of it not K Quanza we've been very
very clear on that no K Quanza here but
I also love that you typically have some
great movies that come out this time of
year right and so that's that's the
season this week kind of officially
kicks it off I didn't realize that I
just thought it kind of happened and I
just loved it and then we were talking
about this thing and I'm like oh well
that makes a whole lot of sense but the
Napoleon Movie um is going to Premiere
and it talks about the French Revolution
and this guy being really short which is
obviously funny but um you know we
thought we would talk about it for you
and uh here's our lad Crowder
entertainment
[Music]
minute it's a good beat what do you guys
know about
Napoleon that he's short I know that's
pretty much the only thing people know
about Napoleon and also that he went
into where where was it what's the city
he went to in Russia it starts with an M
an M he didn't go to Moscow he was
trying no he went South he went the
other way he went through Ukraine over
to like Stalingrad Leningrad they keep
changing the name it's one of the grads
he went there and died just like Hitler
did in World War II um I don't know
unless he did try to march on Moscow
maybe he did I I don't know I don't know
my history you just don't be going into
Russia wi he went to Russia in winter
and it really
everybody's tried to do it but anyway
you're going to find out a little bit
more about that and we're going to watch
the entire trailer what is this Tool Man
2 and a half minutes long two and a half
minutes two and a half minutes so here
is the new Napoleon biopic prepares
tomorrow take a look at the
[Music]
trailer oh Apple original there we go no
doubt you'll seen the chaos in the
streets
we must make an example our France fing
Phoenix is ugly enough for the role he's
a great actor what would you do if this
assignment of defense was transfer his
voice
too
yeah his ears that's fine don't know why
brilliant
successes he was dripped out
though I hate your
words all the
rip what is this costume you have on
this is my
uniform are you a
troll what is your name Napoleon has the
course of my life just changed riveting
Napoleon no wonder they don't look the
same jerk but those in power will only
see me as a
sword I suggest you take the throne as a
king holding
on shall we
[Applause]
vote this ver has held spoiler he didn't
Long Live no a great
trailer good it's not
bad
you think I think the Tyrant part is
what we'll focus
on you are just a tiny little brute is
nothing without
me oh all your is uniting forces against
me what's the outcome of this if you
don't
succeed death for everyone your magesty
we are discovered
good it's a trap
I'm the first to admit when I make a
mistake very
cold
God wonderful I simply never do
oh that's that's that's an awesome
trailer that's a fantastic trailer all
right look I will give it to you that is
a really cool looking trailer I like it
that quote didn't age well though I I
don't have a problem admitting when I
make a mistake I just never
do
whoops apparently there wasn't enough
ice for you to sink the enemy into
because you guys it's like one of the
worst defeats in history like everybody
refers to that March I I believe it was
a march on Moscow right they made it to
Moscow and they they that's when they
went scorched Earth on Moscow and they
fled it so it was abandoned by the time
Napo there but Napoleon I think
basically just made the he he had that
that that thing that dictators do where
they think they can never be wrong and
they have nobody that will give them
wise counsel and tell them hey look
marching on this place in winter when
people can just you know I don't know
freeze to death or die of disease it's
probably a bad idea we can just wait
till spring it's going to be sunnier a
little easier for everybody and he just
chose not to do that but however I I
think if you want to to see a short
French guy with a chip on his shoulder
you can go and watch Ellen degenerous
reruns and save the box office prices I
don't know maybe that's just me do me a
favor though and like if you plan on
seeing this movie uh and you know just
hit that you know the thing you may not
have the the funny sounding Mallet but
you know do your best impression when
you actually do it so just I think we're
going to go into a little bit more depth
here and kind of give you a bit of
history about what's going on here
because a lot of people when you start
talking about uh Wars and you start
talking about these kind of iconic
figures and revolutions like we tend to
understand our American Revolution we
understand where that came from we
understand how that happened and
unfolded we don't really talk much about
France's Revolution or really anything
in in Europe pre World War II it's
almost like World War II was the
beginning of history for a of people um
in Europe meaning us thinking about
Europe and we talked about World War I
the other day and we're like man most
people don't know much about that either
so let's jump into a little bit of this
so Napoleon LED France from 1799 to
1815 it was a very tumultuous time in
France's uh uh after you know kind of
following France's revolution of 1789
and the subsequent kind of quote unquote
reign of terror uh but you you had a
couple of points here Lane that you
wanted to kind of talk about that kind
of encapsulate that time yeah I mean you
quote unquote I guess cuz there's
different periods of when that might
have been but this is the guillotine era
so when you hear the reign of terror and
you associate the guillotine and all the
executions in Fr good old days that's
this time and the Off With Their Heads
robes Pierre this is the time that we're
talking about and it kind of what who's
robes Pierre you just said it like
everybody knows it well he would have
been kind of the leader of this
revolution at its beginning right so
we're going to learn more about kind of
what he did but it's this that set the
path for Napoleon to take power right
and it's important to understand these
things kind of happen uh throughout
history but this was a very kind of
stark contrast between their Revolution
and our Revolution right both of the
revolutions were products of the Age of
Enlightenment with bir ideas like
Classical liberalism socialism Marxism
not the best ideas sometimes but they're
big ideas are ideas they are ideas you
can't take that away but also reforms
within judeo-christian uh religions as
well right so let's start off with the
American Revolution uh and we the kind
of the philosophies that underg guarded
these revolutions so we have the
Declaration of Independence which
famously proclaims this that we hold
these truths to be self-evident sounds
corny not a joke think about it we hold
these truth to be
self-evident all men and women created
by go you know the you know the
thing most of his voters don't know the
thing they don't know the thing now he
added wom didn't even have the thing on
on like a quote you could
read I do cuz I don't want to go you
know the most important thing the thing
you got to tell people the thing here
I'll tell you the thing we hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created this is an important thing
by the way all men are created equal
that they are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights that
among these are life liberty and the
pursuit of the thing happiness right
that's the first time that people had
bothered to write that stuff down in the
same place and use it as a founding
document for a country and the thing
we'll talk about some of the key points
in this but obviously this is one of the
most important things that has ever been
written down you don't want to Bumble
through it now just you know give
yourself a little bit of a pass you see
by the way is anybody else surprised at
how spry he seemed in that Cliff like
his mental faculties weren't quite all
there I understand what you're saying
right now but he had a lot of energy
that was uh that was 2019
2020 so he's quickly
he's yeah W they you know the the hockey
stick curve that they talk about his is
the age hockey stick curve and it's just
falling off a cliff right now oh that's
what happens they find your Coke in the
West Wing that's true take it away from
you how do you think he was functioning
this is an important document you don't
want to screw around and mess it up look
I get it people make mistakes but this
is a bad one to make it just it's like
messing up the words uh to the national
anthem like if you're a singer and you
just do it right through the I mean you
would just have to make sure you don't
mess that one up if you're ever going to
quote don't mess this quote up okay how
big of an do you have to be to
be in that office and and not know that
line especially after preparing for the
speech yeah I can understand forgetting
something in a moment you're like man I
know this and I can't believe that I'm
forgetting this right now I get it
that's not one of those moments though
and you're you're you're the person that
can't do that Thomas Jefferson rolling
over in his grave exactly even if you
have to pull it out on a piece of
parchment and go you know
what and read it that's fine just do
that we would have given you a pass we'
have made fun of you a little bit for
having to do that but we would not be
making fun of you the same way that we
are now okay so French Revolution there
are people outside the Roosevelt Hotel
in New York City sleeping on the
sidewalk that know that Preamble they
the uh sorry the Declaration of
Independence see you almost did it you
almost did it and we were going to be
making fun of you for years and years to
come but we won't now you know because
you thank you for your thing Josh thank
you
for that's what she said know
uh on second
thought didn't I anyway uh French
Revolution not that thing you know the
other thing the other thing oh yes with
the guy in the place and the the God
thing right okay so what we really need
to set up with this is just how
diametrically opposed these two ideas
are and kind of the two camps that
they've created in the world that we're
seeing today that's why we're covering
it because it's just as uh tangible
today as it was when these revolutions
were taking place it's it's where all of
these and I I say it's where all of
these terrible ideas um kind of
originate not not originate but maybe
close yeah they kind of come together
and and they really start to infect
culture and civilization in a way that
is incredibly negative saying that God
created us with rights that are not
given to us by man is fantastic because
those are not rights that can ever be
taken by man because they're given to us
by God I have them no matter what black
brown Asian American anywhere else I
have those rights no matter what as a
human being those rights I possess them
with the rights that are outlined in
other important kind of founding
documents or declarations they are
rights given to you by the state which
means that they can be taken away on a
whim right that's the huge difference
here in what that will lead to so French
Revolution Declaration of the rights of
man and of the citizen it talks about
Liberty equality and fraternity hm a
little bit different right so the big
difference here is that word equality
equality is not a part of our Revolution
it is not a part of the American idea
now you may say well you want some
equality no no no what I'm talking about
is equal outcomes that's equality right
you want you want everybody to have the
same outcome in life you want everybody
to have the same kind of end result you
have you switch it with equity in this
situation sorry you could just switch it
with the word equity and that's what the
french were that's where they exactly
that's what they really meaning here
right we're talking about equal
opportunity we want everybody to have
the same footing as a human being that
is endowed by their creator with rights
that's a huge huge difference right so
on the other hand when you're talking
about the French Revolution um they were
really getting at and this is this is
not something that I knew they were
really attacking privilege yes and I
understand being kind of in the feudal
system where your Birthright basically
determined what your life was going to
be like so if you're born into a high
family then you know fantastic life was
going to be much better for you than it
was going to be for somebody who was
born as a peasant or some kind of surf
right I get it but here's here's the
thing they made a mistake they made a
mistake in their correction in my
opinion right so let's just talk about
the first part it says all men are born
equal and free of
privilege that sounds good on the face
let's let's imagine that you're right
now uh in a in a society where birth is
more important than let's say
achievement or skill or anything else
that you can contribute to society you
would probably think like okay yeah
privilege let's get rid of that that's
fine so this is the pendulum swinging
back and it doesn't necessarily work
well for everybody and so here's
Napoleon uh talking about it so Liberty
is a necessity felt only by a not very
numerous class so not a lot of people
experience Liberty it can therefore be
restricted with impunity equality on the
other hand pleases the multitude that's
what I was getting at the multitudes
look at the word equality and go yeah I
want that the problem is every time we
see a society trying to shoot for
equality it never lifts Society it
always suppresses Society it always
reduces it to the lowest common
denominator because that's the only way
that you can have equality of all
outcomes for people is if you say hey I
have high performers so instead of
taking people and making sure that they
can compete with the high performers and
get up to this level of achievement I
need to lower the level of achievement
so that everybody kind of equally is
mediocre that's what you see in these
societies around the world and you know
speaking of mediocre here's AOC
explaining what it means to her today
our access and our ability and our
guarantee to having a home comes before
someone else's privilege to earn
a oh that's entirely derivative of the
French thinking at the time the French
and the Americans at the time were in
very s similar situations where the
monarchs and the kind of uh the the
buasi or whatever class you want to
refer to them we're living very large
and they're living very by very poor
means they don't have a lot going on so
they look and say we need to change this
the difference is the French said we
need to change by destroying and not
really worrying about what comes next
the Americans always knew once they took
down the Monarch class that there was
something else and that was just as much
there were just as
much a problem there was going to be
just as much danger in the new state
that they created if they weren't to
check themselves they would just become
a new monarch class yeah exactly right
and the equality of outcome it it can't
like I said be achieved by anything
other than oppression but it's not just
that it's top- down government right you
need a top- down government to be able
to achieve that kind of end result I
mean think about this like the the
fundamental difference between a free
market having the ability with all of
its faults by the way sometimes the free
market takes a little while to
self-correct but it does that's why we
talk about letting businesses fail we're
like oh that would terrible for the
banking system for a little while but it
would actually correct and for the long
run be much better for everybody here
because we're like oh that's a really
bad way to trade that's a bad way to do
business and we have to stop doing that
otherwise we will go out of business the
market is fine as long as the government
doesn't come in and try and correct the
issues that naturally should work
themselves out you should have pain
there should be pain when people make
mistakes it's the only way you learn but
when the government comes in and they
say they will be the force that takes
care of everything they will be the
force that Smooths out all of the rough
edges and also brings down these
billionaires who don't have a right to
have the money I don't understand it
like it doesn't make any sense to me
because they're like oh well they have
too much money they they didn't get this
money by Norm like normal means okay are
you saying they broke the law well no
maybe they didn't break the law but
we'll find a law potentially that they
could have broken we just don't like the
fact that they have a lot of money it's
anti-competitive why is it
anti-competitive are they offering a an
inferior service that uh nobody wants no
a lot of people want their service and
it's actually pretty nice to have
everything delivered by Amazon anywhere
on the planet right now essentially if
you'd like it but we just don't like the
fact that they're doing such a good job
in getting all the business I don't
understand guys I don't understand that
kind of argument because it presumes
that taking Jeff Bezos as the guy who
did Amazon and putting Jeff Bezos as the
President of the United States who's
controlling everything that you do and
you have no rights is not the same
because that's what they want to do just
be clear it's different people so Bezos
is going to stay over here and be the
Amazon guy but the equivalent is going
to come over here maybe not as bright as
Bezos cuz he actually had to build a
business and make a living the
equivalent is going to come over here
and say hey we know everything to do for
you let us take care of everything we're
going to have all of the Power we're
basically a monopoly in government just
not in business because business ooh bad
they make a profit government I just
steal your money it's not really called
a profit it's just called taxes right
that's the equivalent that that you
don't you don't get to see that as
clearly but that's what it's needs so
you get to see this in France's
Declaration of the rights of man that we
talked about just a second ago here let
me just read some quotes here social
distinctions may be founded only upon
the general good nobody nor individual
May exercise any Authority which does
not proceed directly from the nation law
can only prohibit s such actions as are
hurtful to society and you had a point
here about Russo's General will versus
this would be John Lock yeah so here's
where you really see the main influences
of the two revolutions where the
Americans were influenced uh mostly by
John Lock and his his preeminent desire
to see the rights of the individual
upheld those inali
inalienable inalienable rights you life
liberty and property yeah alien life
alien life bro you know the thing yeah
the French got most of their inspiration
from rouso which was kind of on board
with lock in a lot of ways but at the
end of the day he really um put forward
this idea called the general will which
is yes those rights need to be protected
from government until they violate the
general will with all that is is the
idea that the needs of the many outweigh
the needs of the few right which in turn
becomes your pure democracy which
becomes your mob rule right and that's
what lock saw and that's what the
American Founders saw but the French and
rouso had a totally different idea of
how Society should operate and it is the
greater good yeah Theory there's
just Josh is this something that like is
it it feels like this is so obvious this
truth is so obvious that left to our own
devices we're inherently evil and lazy
those are two things that you're pretty
much going to find throughout Society
doesn't mean every person it doesn't
mean every civilization is full of
people like that but typically speaking
and I would say I would make the
argument as a Christian that we're all
left to our own devices without God we
are we are all evil we tend to be
selfish we tend to only look out for
ourselves and not seek the common good
uh by sacrificing which is a different
thing by you know giving it to people
that's a different thing than taxes or
being forced to do things but we're
typically evil and lazy and if you just
have a society where people don't have
the ability to go out and freely
participate in Commerce and the
government is going to take care of them
it it's just going to lead to more is
that not obvious to everybody yeah yeah
I mean it kind of um I don't know I
think it's hard to tell now cuz we
already know that that you know it's
already in our heads that knowledge is
already there so it's hard to kind of
theorize if it wasn't there no I mean
but now and people are still calling for
this today like we don't have one
example of a utopian kind of paradise
that worked we have countless examples
of people trying to set this up um there
was a Netflix documentary about one up
in like Washington Oregon maybe Idaho I
can't remember exactly where it was they
tried to set up like this this this guy
was supposed to be like a guru and it
was wild maybe wild was actually in the
title yeah something like that uh it was
it was crazy
and they're like hey we're going to set
up this like everybody's equal except
for you know this one spiritual leader
who's above everybodys to sleep with a
lot of ladies everybody other than equal
you know of course and then they bust in
all these people to vote out the towns
like uh that definitely happens that c
that cult type work there's always at
least one person who's headstrong and
and willing to you know fight for the
power yeah you have like a carismatic
leader yeah and then they can just kind
of mold the the I would say evil and
lazy I think people are evil la lazy
Josh lazy I wouldn't say evil and lazy I
would just say ignorant and manipul
manipulable
manipulatable
manipul yeah I know what you mean easy
to manipulate very Hobs and the
Leviathan right people are lazy and so
that's where the social contract has to
come from yeah and that's the idea that
Lo and rouso had that was totally
different on what that social contract
was with Lo it was a social contract
with the monarchs or the aristocracy
that they are supposed to only so far as
going their responsibilities to protect
inali rights where with rouso he thought
the social contract was amongst the
Sovereign or amongst the people and as
soon as one person's individual needs
violated that greater group identity
well they had to be taken out yeah
absolutely and freedom yeah Freedom
didn't exist Freedom doesn't exist at
the end of something like this right
especially if your freedom gets in the
way of the prosperity of the many now
it's fantastic when you're a part of the
many because you can just sit there and
uh the government's going to take care
of you or they're going to try to create
a system that will take care of you but
it it it only takes you so far that's
why a lot of people are in the many I
know you see college now well yeah what
but the welfare system when people are
like oh nobody likes no nobody likes
being on welfare but you know how many
people are are comfortable being on
welfare maybe they don't like it I don't
know I won't use I won't use that word
some people say that you say that I
would say they're comfortable with bu
Riders yeah but they're they're
comfortable with it you're giving them
just enough to be comfortable I had a
job one time at a country club and I was
poor very poor at the time and it was
you know pretty soon after college after
I'd started a business up in Ohio and
moved back here and you were around
wealth you were around wealthy people
and nice things and you worked in a nice
place and occasionally they would give
you tickets to games and stuff like that
if they couldn't go at the last minute
like oh you want these tickets here you
go awesome you were wealth adjacent but
you were not wealthy and it sucks you in
because it gives you this feeling of
actually being where where they are and
you're not you're one of them for a
while because you develop relationships
with people who are very wealthy and you
look up 20 years later and people that
still work there for 10 20 30 years
making very little money to be honest
like you know definitely not a
high-paying job and you're like wait a
minute like I've had this feeling like I
was around it but I never actually
achieved any success like other than
being in that group and not everybody if
you work at a country club there's
probably people that run it to make a
lot of money but the servers and other
people like banquet captain and things
like that they're not making a lot of
money they're just doing that and you're
adjacent to it and that's that's what I
feel like this is like the government
gives you just enough to feel like
you're okay just to feel like you have
enough but you don't ever really
actually have enough and you certainly
don't have any pride in your achievement
in life because you're living off of
someone else there's no way to look at
that and say I'm fulfilling my purpose
right so not only is there a huge like
kind of understand a difference in
understanding of the revolutions about
what you're going to kind of found your
country on on the idea that the
government is not there to give you
rights but necessarily to make sure that
the playing field is somewhat level as
best they can right and make sure they
don't get in the way of your rights and
your ability to go out and pursue
happiness right and their OPP
opportunity really was to say that the
government is just going to come in and
tell you that hey everybody all this
privilege that existed over here yeah
it's not going to exist it's going to
exist over here in the government now in
in a much more Consolidated way and so
everybody's going to be slightly better
off actually probably worse off
but don't worry we'll provide for you it
wasn't just that difference it was a
difference in religion right so in the
American Revolution we had Christian
Origins you ask me how I know that I
don't know let's go back to the thing
again and see what it says Declaration
of Independence we hold these truths to
be self-evident that all men dot dot dot
yeah we'll go through that are endowed
by their creator with certain
inalienable rights okay very good we go
with the Creator I love that fantastic
right yes why do you love that because
we have a freedom of religion here we do
and you can you can worship whatever
deity or God you want to whatever
Creator whether they be fake or real
there's only yeah whether they be fake
or real you you have your Creator and
that's that you're you're given un what
what is it see see hard phrase
unalienable
rights it also references the laws of
nature and of Nature's God and closes by
appealing to the Supreme judge of the
world noting that siners uh Reliance on
protection of Divine Providence they say
those kinds of words a lot let's that
with the French Revolution that sought
the removal of religion in 1790 the
Civil constitution of clergy was a law
passed that among other things made the
clergy paid employees of the government
required all members of the clergy to
swear an oath of loyalty to the nation
and nullified the church's rights as a
feudal land owner well I understand that
they want to get some of that land back
and the church owned a lot of it no
that's that's a really bad idea 1793 the
law of suspects they had good names for
things the law of suspect not their
declaration though that was pretty
stupid it sounded like offbrand cereal
what is it the Rights of Man and the of
man and of the citizen Thomas Jefferson
helped write that did he yep he almost
got you know what he saved the best for
us let's just put it that way well it
was a sequel Ah that's right you can
always go back and correct your mistakes
you're like I'm going to try it out on
you first France I didn't quite nail
that um so in 1793 the law of suspects
that was passed all priests and all
persons protecting them are liable to
death on the spot or you know
potentially if you have time maybe you
can make it into an
[Music]
event yeah Guillotine not so much fun so
destruction of all crosses bells and
other external signs of worship
destruction of statues plaques and icon
icon iconography I almost said it
iconography with us today from places of
worship I can't do it ah taking down of
statues that sounds a little bit
familiar to me like that's the thing
that we should be doing is taking down
statues take a whole bunch down they
they did yeah but don't worry about that
equality exactly well and then another
in 1793 The Cult of reason was
instituted and it acted like a church
like you know congregational Services
symbolism and worship but they denied
the existence of any deity or
Supernatural forces and Disney
originally had the and and we obtained
you know what their poster um of the
film was actually going to
be well okay looks net
flixy
yeah I don't think so I don't think so
Kathleen Kennedy was heavily
[Laughter]
involved oh my gosh well Josh you
actually were telling me a little story
about uh Napoleon oh yeah his in his
thing yeah Napo when when Napoleon died
uh on that Island uh St Helena or
whatever it's called he the corner cut
off his penis in the autopsy did he
think he was a woman no oh okay so
different surgery no no I think it was
just he was taking it for personal
reasons but
he did they have taxer yeah I don't know
I don't think it's stuffed I don't think
that it's uh mounted and stuffed but
yeah cut off his penis is this real yeah
this is real I heard it on I read it on
NPR pis radio NP Napoleon's penis radio
I don't think that's true no yeah know
it is true it is true and it's been uh
it's been passed from private collection
to Private Collection um yeah they cut
it off and then they they took it to
Europe and there a whole thing they had
it on display in New York in 1927 no yes
it was on display on yes is that what
was responsible for Black Friday like
the economy crashes soon after they said
it looks like a shriveled up uh
something I can't remember what they
called it but it looks shriveled and
small and they were like he was short
and that's yeah that's the uh they
should do that to every Tyrant they
should cut off your member yeah anybody
that was a tyrant unless had a hog like
I don't want to be
like you know I don't want I don't want
Kim jong-un's giant Korean penus just
making us all look stereotypes it's a
contradiction of terms there giant but
uh yeah the rumor is that's where
Napoleon complex comes from really well
I made that part out but the rest comp
and it it makes men in their Middle Ages
buy Porsches yes oh yeah it does Mak
sense penis penis got it look I hope you
go I hope you go and see the movie not
the penis go see the movie I don't know
where the penis is can somebody do some
research and find out where Napoleon's
penis actually is got to know it's like
an infinity stone
yeah only not the infinity bone yeah
there we
go oh we just made the French Revolution
fun all right right there we go so look
there go see the movie I think it's
actually going to be a good movie I like
Walken Phoenix he's he's actor yeah
really it's it should be good we'll see
how it goes but just remember this and I
know look we got a little wonky on this
on purpose because most of you guys
don't understand the French Revolution
and the American Revolution and how they
were so diametrically opposed in the way
of thinking American Revolution rights
given by God not man personal Liberty
more important than equal outcomes and
they embraced judeo-christian values and
you see the natural results of that
French Revolution rights flow down from
government equality of outcome is more
important than personal Liberty and
anti-religion in favor of the state and
government and you have seen the results
of that they build the magino line and
then you know Hitler just goes around
they're idiots I think it's easy to see
which one of these is the best and uh
it's it's not even close to man what do
you got so research chimed it and said
that Napoleon's penis is in the armpit
of North America AKA New Jersey and also
Jersey has Napoleon penis Chris Christie
sitting on Napoleon
penis listen I know we got to get out of
here super quick on this segment but the
thing to know about the French
Revolution and revolutions like this
they're unwinable you have to keep
fighting because they're always needs to
be a Target and you're always going to
end up losing no matter how pure you are
robes Pierre started this with his reign
of terror he eventually got his head cut
off by the guillotine you see this on
the left eventually you're not going to
be pure enough for the ideological cause
you're going to be kept you're even if
you're popular at the time with it
doesn't matter eventually are never
going to win this kind of ideological
battle we'll always be pink hair out
there there will to keep you in line
there'll be a Pinker head of hair out
there there's always a Pinker head of
hair yeah yeah somebody can always put
their penis on display in Jersey too
write that one down 49 minutes poly not
you know at the time anyway whatever so
hey guys look it's been a couple of
weeks since we released the three pages
of the Nashville Manifesto um one of the
the biggest if not the biggest Story of
the Year still no action has been taken
by uh uh the police department yet to
release the rest we're we're pushing as
hard as we can and this is not again
this is not something where we're doing
this for no reason we actually want to
apply as much pressure as we can to make
them release this information so we are
collecting signatures to demand that
release of the Nashville Covenant School
shooters Manifesto so go to release the
manifesto. comom right now do it for me
just your email address your first name
last name sign that petition so that we
can literally walk in and slap these
things down repeatedly because there's a
lot lot of sheet sheets of paper uh
because we have so many people doing
that many many many many people have
signed up right now and we want you to
do that again go to releas theem
manifesto. comom and just sign it for us
and look M Club undercover we're already
investigating some explosive leads that
I talked to you about off the top um
we've got tons and tons of tips coming
in from all corners of society it's not
just about
this particular case that we're talking
about but there are so many things
coming in so if you have a tip send it
to lwc tips protonmail.com we will get
our team on it and we will get to the
bottom of it okay to be clear to be
clear these are investigative journalism
TW tips yes not Napoleon tips not well
not those tips okay just the real tips
okay if you want those tips go to New
Jersey yeah I want to know where in
Jersey this is I want to send some
business their way like look we want to
go look at Napoleon a smallis I don't
know why I did Italian that's all I
really know he does it's in his personal
collection why would you keep a man's
penis anyway I mean if somebody was like
if somebody was like hey I uh you know
the Moa Lisa it's already bought but uh
I got this I got Napoleon's penis yeah
just doesn't make any sense 15 bucks and
pizza hey did you hear that Elon Musk is
being accused of being an anti-semite I
heard he was an anti-semite oh no that's
true according to Media Elon mus
worst anti-semite we've ever known right
but here's the thing he just dropped an
incredible massive lawsuit against Media
Matters and I I I I really do feel like
this is the tide turning moment I had
you guys comment on it a minute ago
because I think what happened is they
finally overreach there's actual damages
that you can attach to this it's not
just reputational damages which are much
much harder to put a figure on but Elon
Musk just exposed something about Media
Matters that I think we've all known
their pieces of crap right we've known
that for a long time we've talked about
him on the show but he just exposed
something that a lot of people are
jumping on including the guys over at
truth Donald Trump's uh uh uh kind of
social media company they filed the
lawsuit with 20 uh different against 20
different media companies um but also
Ken Paxton the attorney general for
Texas he's jumped on this and I think
you'll see more people start to jump on
this I know Rumble has started to jump
on this as well and it's not just about
people saying bad things about you
that's not that's not the issue if
they're reporting accurately fine you
have to deal with it if it's out of
context or if it's an outright lie and
they know it or if it's contrived that's
a different story but before we get to
all of that let's just take a look at a
little bit of how we got here the less
than perfect launch comes amid a weakend
of controversy for SpaceX founder and
CEO Elon Musk with advertisers fleeing
his platform X formerly known as Twitter
after musk replied to an anti-semitic
tweet that accused Jews of hating white
people he retweeted a post a highly
offensive anti-semitic post Tech
billionaire Elon Musk is under Fire for
spreading anti-semitic and racist hate
as for Elon Musk well he's under Fire
for stoking specifically right now
anti-Semitism Elon Musk is taking fire
for green with anti-semitic posts on X
Elon Musk uh openly endorsed this
anti-semitic conspiracy theory ex owner
Elon Musk is now Under Fire for agreeing
with anti-semitic comment I I love the
soundboard there thank you very much
Jake Tapper is pushing and I I'm very I
have a lot of issues with Tapper maybe
we'll do a what a piece of of poop I
can't see did we already do one on him
on Jake I don't think we did if we did I
I don't remember it maybe we did it's
possible but anyway he discussed white
replacement Theory um on Sunday I
actually listened to this live on Sunday
unfortunately and the replacement Theory
basically Alle alleges that leftwing
Elites are trying to replace whites in
Western nations with non-white
population like they said they are
trying to do well other than that um
yeah so but here look I just just so you
have understanding of what that here's
the actual series of tweets that led to
these accusations right so on November
15th breaking bat bot I don't know Baht
posted onx okay Jewish communities have
been pushing the exact kind of
dialectical hatred against whites that
they claim to want to stop using or
people to stop using against them I'm
deeply disinterested in giving the
tiniest crap now about Western Jewish
populations coming to the disturbing
realization that those hordes of
minorities that support flooding their
country don't exactly like them too much
you want truth said to your face there
it is and so okay that that that's out
there a little bit right he's basically
saying that these people don't give a
crap about what you think now do me a
favor in going to some of these European
countries that have had uncontrolled
unmitigated uh U uh immigration from
wherever whenever whyever and and see if
they would say hey this maybe was a bad
idea for a lot of different reasons they
don't care about our culture they don't
care about who we are they just want to
come in and do their thing right so
here's what Elon said you have said the
actual truth now if he'd have left it at
that people can have an they can have an
argument and say what did Elon mean by
that what exactly was the truth there I
I don't like what he said I don't like
okay but Elon didn't just say that right
but it did spur countless headlines
pushing the narrative that musk is now
an anti-semite because he's agreeing
with this whole kind of replacement
Theory uh ideology and that's an
anti-semitic thing to say but buried in
these
articles are when Elon Musk himself gave
the context and further furthered the
conversation right so here's that same
conversation the ADL unjustly attacks
the majority of the West despite the
majority of the West supporting the
Jewish people of Israel really quickly
just pause right the ADL he specifically
calls out a group that he's talking
about and then talks a little bit more
about it later this is because they
cannot by their own tenants criticize
the minority groups who are their
primary threat it is not right and needs
to stop you write that this does not
extend all Jewish communities but it is
also not limited to the ADL so he's
saying it's not all communities but it's
not just limited to the ADL he's pointed
out the ADL is one of the biggest
problems right and at the risk of being
repetitive I am deeply offended by adl's
messaging and other any other groups who
push deao anti-white racism or
anti-asian racism or racism of any kind
I'm sick of it stop now that sounds a
whole lot like he's not for racism
that's what you got from that yeah yeah
interesting I mean there's it seems like
it almost seems like there's context
right but yeah you know unfortunately
for him the the latest SpaceX launch
didn't really didn't really help his
case I I missed that in the original
launch I had no idea that's my feed my
feed cut out before that yeah mine too
gosh how do you do the smoke rings like
that that's pretty impressive he trolls
on a whole new level he does I don't
agree with it but you know if you just
read the articles or listened to the
headlines uh uh written about him you'd
think man that's par for the course I
mean elon's pretty anti-semitic he
probably did that I like how a few days
ago everyone on Twitter was giving him
crap because he uh he tweeted out that
if you say from The River To The Sea
palestin will be free you will uh you'll
get Shadow banned or whatever yeah
obviously being pro and then immediately
anti-semitic Elon Musk I it's like how
can he be that's a direct call for
genocide the first one against who uh oh
the Jews oh the anti-semite doesn't like
that stupid yeah this is this is
completely GED up but if if all you do
is check in on CNN or MSNBC or some
other Li why would you do that but a lot
of people do that you know they have to
catch flights so they see CNN on in the
airport if you catch those guys you're
like oh elon's anti-semitic well that's
a shame and they don't actually address
the substance of what he said they just
make the claim because he re he tweeted
this about this spot that was
anti-semitic and it's like oh hold on
there's so much that you have to get
into and look he's right it's not just
the ADL but do me a favor comment do you
think Elon what he said do you think
that rises to the level of
anti-Semitism let me know I think I know
what the answer is going to be but you
know what just in case you guys were
worried about it he was defended by
prominent Jewish voices on the matter
including Ben Shapiro and and Jonathan
green blat from the ADL let me see let
me show you what he wrote this is an
important and welcome move by Elon Musk
I appreciate this leadership and
fighting hate that I think was in
response to the from The River To The
Sea comment that Elon made saying that
that was after this controversy already
started already started yes so the ADL
apparently can kind of see through this
but Jake Tapper Intrepid journalists
can't is that what I'm to understand
that every other journalist out there
who's covering this and saying Elon Musk
is anti-Semitic this same media machine
that keeps pushing for a ceasefire that
Israel's war criminals that keep saying
Netanyahu is trying to commit genocide
these people can go right to hell
because they don't have they have no
principles and they're just trying to
sto for clicks we know this they're done
their days are numbered they they are
well didn't they also say everything was
safe and effective and uh a danger to
our democracy and they all have a script
they all get past the script and they
repeat the script and that was a script
it's going to bite him in the ass I
think it really is and unfortunately
that's what we're seeing right now they
they their writers put a narrative out
there whoever controls the producers
whoever is controlling what goes out and
apparently Jake Tapper doesn't have time
to do his own research maybe he's too
important no none of those talking do
any research they don't look at this and
go wait a minute nope Elon Musk they
just go ah I don't like Elon mus
fantastic let's run with he's an
anti-semite because who's going to check
us because we're the media we said it so
it must be true well this actually after
this like after during kind of in the
midst of
this Fallout from his tweet Media
Matters and this is this is what really
gets me excited talking about the demise
of Media Matters they posted an article
with this
headline basically just just tying the
knot themselves as musk endorses
anti-semitic conspiracy theory X has
been placing ads for Apple Bravo IBM
Oracle and XFinity why is Bravo next to
pro- naazi content I love the Bravo one
that is hilarious Bravo none of you
would exist in Nazi Germany come on
Bravo that's
mostly it's like all the gay reality lot
of gay reality stuff yeah we Eye For The
Straight Guy all that junk that's on
there you remember that it's the gay
channel is that the keeping up with the
Kardashian channel I don't think is it I
don't know that's pretty gay too no
don't care so that's what he said Bruce
J's am no hey look if you're IBM do you
want your ad placed next to pro-nazi
content no of course not and so
responding to this article a lot of
these companies they pulled advertising
from X right Apple Disney Paramount
Warner Brothers IBM and in a public
statement IBM even noted IBM has zero
tolerance for hate speech and
discrimination and we have immediately
suspended all advertising on X while we
investigate this entirely unacceptable
situation interesting I didn't know they
pulled sponsorships because of this
article it's because of this now it's
not because Elon Musk put out a tweet
that they said was anti-Semitic no no no
no no they're totally fine with that
most likely yeah exactly unfortunately
what happens is they see this article
and go we can't have our ads next to
Nazi content who reads medium m nobody
does somebody picked it up and put it
out yeah exactly so musk actually
responds and completely destroys or lays
the foundation for the destruction of
Media Matters on November 18th musk went
what in his words said he was going
thermonuclear and he dropped a laundry
list of claims exposing their practices
being medium matters to manipulate the
public advertisers Media Matters created
an alternate account and curated posts
and advertising appearing on the
account's timeline to misinform
advertisers about the placement of their
posts once the curated once they curated
this fee they repeatedly refesh
refreshed their timelines to find a rare
instance of ads serving next to content
they chose to follow our logs indicate
that they forced a scenar scario
resulting in 13 times the number of ads
served compared to the median ads served
to an X User of the
5.5 billion ad Impressions on X that day
less than 50 total ad Impressions were
served against all of the organic
content featured in the Media Matters
article what he is basically saying is
that Media Matters had accounts that
they use that were over 30 days old
because if you don't have an account
that's over 30 days old you don't get
ads right mhm none of the ads get pushed
to it so they they proactively used
accounts that they would get ads on
right they Then followed only the
advertisers and extreme content only and
then went to see if those ads would show
up in their timeline next to the kind of
quote unquote extreme content maybe some
of it was extreme I'm not even really
addressing that I'm addressing what they
did they couldn't get the result they
wanted and so they constantly refresh
refresh refresh refresh refresh to get
Those ads to post next to these people
right saying terrible things so they go
C IBM you're right next to this person
who hates Jews right you can't you can't
be next to this comment because that's
bad and so you should pull your
advertising from X because they're
serving up your ads it was contrived two
cases that they showed one case one
human being on the planet saw that ad
next to that content guess who it was it
was the Media Matters guy they did did
it with their media matter it was the
only person that saw the ad on the
entire planet right in another case two
people saw the ad one was the Media
Matters guy and one they don't even know
who it was they don't know if it was
just a random regular user if it was
another Media Matters person that saw it
so they basically lied about this and
look they actually so Michael
shellenberger he was one of the guys
that did the Twitter files I believe he
actually they they tried to corroborate
these findings and could not right they
meaning they couldn't replicate what was
happening in the Media Matters article
so Michael's actually saying yeah elon's
right everything he just said is correct
we couldn't replicate this scenario in
real life but if we tried to kind of you
know contrive it mayell so mayell I
almost did the Maybelline thing with
maybe see what I did
there all day see what happens real
quick from research and something we
talked about earlier of those companies
that left IBM right pulled advertising
for musk's anti-Semitism which is
awfully funny because IBM during the
Holocaust actually provided the Nazis
with Punch Cards to keep track of how
many Jews were going to the
concentration camps from the getto
really yeah wow it's like Hugo Boss
saying not by our ads no IBM's like we
don't want to bring up this again
yeah absolutely consequently uh cocol
and Adidas still very heavily sponsor
very heavily Ford also yeah very very
invested weird so November 20th uh that
would be yesterday afternoon or so after
the show musk officially dropped a
lawsuit against Media Matters for the
behavior alleged above and so here's
what the suit says Media Matters
knowingly and maliciously manufactured
side by-side images depicting ads next
to racist posts as if they were a
typical ex experience 100% of the
accounts Media Matters followed to
generate the side-by-side images or
either French accounts or large National
Brands like I was talking about even
still they had to engage in excessive
scrolling and refreshing to force that
situation to generate the ads next to
the content no authentic so this is the
different part for me that I didn't have
no authentic user of X has seen any of
the pairings Media Matters ignorant or
inorganically generated right like they
saying you can't find this in nature on
our site doesn't happen right so that
was a huge shoe to drop because Media
Matters just did something to try to
damage that company to damage the brand
to try to make advertisers flee to try
to hurt Elon Musk why because they hate
free speech that's why not because
there's hate speech on the site they
hate Elon Musk that he's successful and
that he's trying to keep X X as a place
where people can actually speak their
mind for the most part there's still
problems that I have with X and we'll
get to those here in just a minute but
on November 20th as well Texas AG Ken
Paxton opens up an investigation into
Media Matters manipulation and uh in
response to mus tweeted fraud both has
has both civil and criminal penalties
which is fantastic because Elon Musk is
basically just doubling down but it's
not just Elon Musk our very own Rumble
CEO Chris pavlovski is also calling out
Media Matters for fraudulent practice is
let me read one of his statements I can
also confirm that Media Matters has
purposefully misrepresented Rumble Media
Matters claimed that ads for Netflix on
Rumble had been placed on videos that
violated their content policies however
before publication of that Media Matters
article there had been zero page views
of that video nobody had seen it nobody
this means that the Media Matters
activist who took the the screenshot was
the first human being to actually view
the Netflix ad though their story left
the false impression that it was a
widespread problem it got even spicier
because Donald Trump starts to weigh in
as well yesterday truth social is suing
20 20 media companies for
defamation look this is huge you've got
massive massive companies now that are
free speech Advocates at the very least
even if imperfect in in X's case but
you've got truth and you've got Rumble
coming out and saying hey we've been
targeted as well this is not just like
Shadow banding where you can't prove it
this is people running hit pieces on us
lying manipulating results in an effort
to try to drive our advertisers away and
it's funny that that kind of stuff
should happen I mean we've actually been
on the the the that end of media M
matters as well and they've come after
us and they've targeted us but they're
not I mean they they target us and they
think they're right they're not always
wrong I don't I don't typically like
addressing Media Matters because you
have a bunch of uh conservatives who
their whole show turns into a back and
forth right I really just find them
incredibly entertaining and the fact
that we know they have a mug club
membership they support the show they
support the show they clip our videos
it's great advertising it's ironic that
they go after SP to try and boycott
sponsors but they pay for a membership
headline reads on YouTube Steven Crowder
said I would like to send out gangs of
people to uh Lynch
pedophile I mean did he what's wrong
with that I mean what did he what did he
what was wrong with that I just I
don't people deserve to have a
gang of friends too it's it's it's a job
pedophiles should die what's the problem
yes it sounds like a win-win to me if
these guys job they thought that was a
hit piece and I'm like that was a puff
piece thank you puff
piece medium matters I'm sorry I was
wrong no I'm not wrong you guys are
pieces of crap and look this happens to
us and other people so often we actually
have our own Stinger made for
[Laughter]
[Music]
them should have given him the double
though I couldn't do it I can't with
these clowns though the truth stuff the
X stuff the rumble stuff that's
obviously all fantastic but I think the
AG is actually getting involved here is
what really exciting it's huge because
the the they can affect a lot of change
right and it it's a shot across the bow
it's not just about Media Matters like
when they they started they started with
$2 million in seed money from move
on.org in the new Democratic Network
they also received a million bucks from
George Soros in 2010 I wonder what their
motivations were yeah I wonder what
their motivations could be but look
Media Matters is not the issue they love
nothing more than right now people are
actually talking about their existence
because most people don't know they
exist or care that they exist rightfully
so I get it what we need to though is
Media held accountable when they
actively try and damage a company and
they do it um I don't know
[Music]
in
and all of the people who have joined us
for 89 bucks a year to subscribe and
like Media Matters yeah like Media
Matters thank you for your subscription
and your support we really appreciate it
I know you broke your mug and no I'm not
sending you a new one by the way if you
did break your mug we will have the
opportunity for we'll have a new page
set up for you to be able to sign up to
get a replacement mug or if you haven't
gotten your mug we've got the new guys
by the way the the the truck you know
you can win the the Raptor and cash
these guys they're fantastic they're
helping us get everybody caught up so
that the the turnaround time going
forward before your mug is shipped
should be down to days if not maybe a
week before it's shipped that's a high
bar I get it if you use a promo code you
have to wait until you actually pay
right if you get a free month or
something like that then it gets out
there but look the only way that we can
survive these attacks is because you
have said hey we want this content we've
gone a little long today that was my
fault but you like this content in Muk
Club you're not going to get short
changed we're going to do we're going to
do Tuesday today because Thursday we
won't have a show we're actually have an
extra segment here where I talk about
things that I certainly can't talk about
here on on YouTube rumble's totally fine
with it they're they're down with it but
the other guys on YouTube they're not
but this is what we have to do we have
to support content that we like not just
by going and watching but by getting
involved and if if it's this show
fantastic mug Club is the way that you
do that we sell merch as well that
supports what we do right great if it's
some other show and there's another way
to support them fantastic do it do it
with your clicks as well but do it with
actually putting money down on things
that you believe in I'm not saying go
and give money to every single cause out
there because there are a lot of worthy
causes that maybe you like go find the
people that absolutely 100% believe the
way that you believe and are willing to
do something with it not just say it but
actually try to get things done to
affect change and support them that is
absolutely the way that we can do this
Josh you're going to be doing a free
show in Taca Comedy Club Thanksgiving
Eve comedy show it's me free with mashed
potatoes if you bring mashed potatoes
you get in free to see Josh yes that's
the only way that's the only way all
right don't you dare bring me green
beans I swear you'll be kicked out of
the city listen we'll talk about some
green beans in just a second cuz green
beans are fantastic but look thank you
very much for joining us we hope you all
have a wonderful and Happy Thanksgiving
enjoy some time with family and friends
if you go out for Black Friday make sure
you're not the one person that gets
killed on Black Friday because we will
probably end up making fun of you
unknowingly it's not our fault we didn't
know it was you stay safe YouTube I
don't care about you piss off we're
[Applause]
coming
I